sponsored by God of War in the new God
of War combat has evolved from the past
god of war games you are now given way
more strategic choices with Kratos new
weapon the Leviathan acts his
impenetrable shield and devastating bare
fists God of War combat feels more
vicious and intentional while the
third-person over-the-shoulder camera
gets you closer to the action than ever
before and with his son at Reyes a
highly skilled and knowledgeable ally
always at his side whose bow and
acrobatic moves play a critical support
weapon in battle the new game is giving
you an incredible amount of strategic
depth to engage in combat the way you
want check out more of the intense
combat from the new game brought to you
by God of War
pre-order and preload the digital deluxe
edition from PlayStation Store to be one
of the first to play it
[Music]